the first certification that I chose was
professional Cloud security engineer
because that's kind of a niche that I
like I all I've always liked security
I've always liked doing I never did it
like full time as a deficit cops for
example
but I've always been curious about it
and having worked in financial industry
and in healthcare I knew a little bit
about securing platforms so that kind of
felt like a natural thing but yeah that
was because I was curious about it that
I had worked in Industries on platforms
that required a lot of security
knowledge and eventually became
comfortable enough to go ahead and say
okay cool I'll I'm gonna go for the
professional security engineer because
that's who I think I am